اهلا بكم الى موجز لاهم الانباء اعلن رئيس
الاوكراني
استعاده مدينه
في هذا اليوم بالتاريخيه واكد ان الوحدات
الخاصه في الجيش الاوكراني موجوده حاليا
وسط مدينه خرسون
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اكتمال عمليات نقل
قواتها من الضفه اليمنى لنهر 2 برو في
مقاطعه خرسون الى ضفه اليسرى من النهر
اوضحت الوزاره انه تم سحب اكثر من
الثلاثين الف جندي وخمسه الاف قطعه من
الاسلحه والمعدات وقال الكلام لان الموقف
من وضع خرسون كجزء من روسيا لم يتغير
اكاد وزير الخارجيه الفرنسيه والبريطانيه
في بيان من باريس على دعم اوكرانيا سياسيا
واقتصاديا وعسكريا البيان المشتركه
بمسمائه ودعم طهران للحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا خصوصا الطائرات الايرانيه
المسيره الوزيران ندى ايضا بانشطه ايران
المزعزع للاستقرار في المنطقه واكد ضمانه
منعها من حيازه اسلحه النوويه وفقا للبيان
المشترك
نقل موقعه بوليتيكو عن مسؤولين
هجوم على السعوديه
في السعوديه
للعراق على حد تعبير
قال قائد الحرس الثوري الايرانيه اللواء
حسين السلامي ان طهران ابلغت اعدائها انها
لن تدعهم ينعمون بالهدوء على حد تعبيره
واضاف ان من وصفه بالعدو يعيش حاله تاهب
منذ ايام واشعر بالرعب وارسل الى ايران
عده رسائل عبر عده دول يطالبها بعدم شنه
اي هجوب
انها الرئيس الاسرائيلي اسحاق هيرتوب
مشاوراته مع قاده الاحزاب التي تمكنت من
تخطي العتبه الانتخابيه حيث اوصى 64 من
اعضاء الكنيسه بتزكيه زعيم النقود
لتشكيل الحكومه الجديده اتصل وكيلو ديوان
الرئاسه الاسرائيليه بمكتب نتنياهو وابلغه
قرار الرئيس
بتشكيل الحكومه
قال الرئيس الاسرائيلي السابق قريبين
ريفلين ان الحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده
المزمل اعلانها الاعلان عنها قريبا ستشكل
خطرا على اسرائيل حديث غريبين نجاء في
حوار مغلق في الكونغرس اليهودي في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وبعد تسرب
اقواله عدا رفل ليؤكد ان النتائج
الانتخابات حددها الشعب وان تمت فائزا
واحده لكنه يشعر بالقلق
حضر الامين العام الاتحاد التونسي للشغل
لنور الدين الطبوبي الحكومه من الاستمرار
فيما وصفه السياسات اللاشعبيه التي تنظر
بانفجارات الاجتماعيه كبيره وجدد التزام
الاتحاد
ومحاولات العوده الى مربع الاستبداد وفق
تعبير
حضرت حركه الشعب في تونس من ان تؤدي
الاوضاع الاجتماعيه والاقتصاديه التي
وصفتها بالمتفجره الى العزوف عن
الانتخابات كما انتقدت الحركات تعامل
الحكومه مع ارتفاع الاسعار وفقدان المواد
الاساسيه والادويه وتنام الهجره غير
النظاميه
من رئيسه التونسيه قيس سعيد الجانبيه الى
ضروره الوعي بان مسار الخامس والعشرين من
يوليو من العام الماضي كان ضروري لانقاذ
الدوله
النهائيه سوف تكون للشعب التونسي حسب
تعبير
نهايه هذا الموجز شكرا لكم والى اللقاء